[Music]
imagine if the internet took hold in
China
imagine how freedom would spread
unrestricted internet access is a source
of strength that country has some of the
toughest internet restrictions in the
world governed in China's tightening up
on internet restrictions it says because
of the number of anonymous postings that
poke fun at the government so you think
they're ultimately gonna be on the right
side of history the Chinese government
appears I am the wind of course in for
sure because nobody can stop this
technology revolution
it's 1987 in West Germany and a
university professor has just got an
email it contains one short sentence
across the great wall we can reach every
corner of the world
he's just received the first email from
China China is embracing the reform and
opening-up policies and the internet and
transparency of information is part of
that policy but it isn't until 1994 that
the internet becomes available to the
public under the presidency of Jiang
Zemin
like many of his compatriots Zhang is
deeply influenced by the work of Alvin
Toffler an American writer whose book
future shock predicts a super industrial
revolution brought about by the
moderation and regulation of Technology
Computers combine facts to make new
knowledge at such high speed that we
cannot absorb but computers are
expensive and hardly anyone owns one so
the internet cafe is born it costs
around 25 yuan or $3 for an hour in the
early days internet speed was really
slow and having a personal computer with
a luxury most of the people who frequent
internet cafes were the more young
tech-savvy generation and they would go
through play games and chat with your
friends anonymously online in 1995 a
former English teacher called Jack Ma
heads to the US on business while he's
there he does a web search for the word
beer and there are no results about
China he returns home and starts an
online Yellow Pages you don't make any
money
you've got extraordinary claims and yet
you make nothing that's internet by 1999
the company Tencent releases oh I seek
you and Jack Ma creates Alibaba it's the
Millennium and the unveiling of the
Golden Shield project which includes a
new surveillance system made up of
content filtering firewalls the system
becomes known around the world as the
Great Firewall of China the government
also employs an army of people that
actively send out social posts
a conversation about lying these people
became known as the 50-cent party the
joke being that they would earn a fee
and every time they spent it out a
social media post it only takes a couple
more years for China to overtake the US
and have the world's most Internet users
fast forward and it's 2012 Xi Jinping is
elected general secretary of the
communist party with a vision of cyber
sovereignty protecting the country's
internet from foreign influence notable
restrictions include winnie-the-pooh
because of comparisons made to Xi
Jinping and the letter M the worst might
think of Chinese internet users being
horribly miserable because they can't
access information freely but the truth
can't be more different
China's younger generations are
perfectly happy living inside the
firewall where they can use the domestic
apps that are screened there really is a
disconnect between China's younger
Internet users and the rest of the world
because of the Great Firewall it doesn't
take long for controversial new laws
which ensure cybersecurity to appear
these grant the government unprecedented
access to foreign companies including
their hardware and sensitive user data
in 2018 Freedom House named China as the
worst country in the world for online
freedom but China soon starts exporting
it to take on the Internet the countries
like Vietnam Uganda and Tanzania in 1987
when that email was sent from China to
West Germany and said across the great
wall we can reach every corner of the
world looks quite ironic right now
because we have a great wall that
literally screams and monitors
everything the vision that early
internet founders had
is very different from China's internet
landscape today
you